[Musique]
lisez moi est-ce que vous pouvez nous
prendre une photo rapidement devant la
fontaine
si vous pouvez nous prendre juste avec
le monument derrière est ce qu'on s'est
rencontrés là il ya un an bien non merci
[Musique]
c'est qui
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
donc non je n'en attendais mais dites
moi qui ai appelé c'est toi c'est que tu
t'appelles la non mais t'es ce qui veut
dire que l'on voit plus tard c'est
françois monsieur ces procès la france
et qui si vous venez en france
bouriez moi je prends une photo mais tu
sais quoi mais va car c'était françois
je suis pas un menteur monsieur la
bienvenue et plan cul sur votre
téléphone
les paroles ne faisait pas d'exciter
françois parce que je connais pas de
françois qu'est ce qu'on s'est
rencontrés là en fait le
qu'est ce qu'il ya
non qu'ils appellent tout d'un coup nous
sommes ravis des clubs avec une culotte
jamais attendre ce genre qu on sera
coulé non greg là il vient de me dire
qu'il y avait une maman en culotte chez
un collègue qui m'a appelé monsieur
c'était pas une photo vous êtes trompé
de prêter un peu hein pourquoi
or voilà en fait c'est un peu gênant
fait qu'est ce que génère pas trop m'en
mêler on sent que vous pouvez leur dire
que ces médias c'est jean-paul juste
parce qu'on en fait moi je serai jamais
mentir en fusion entre pas là dedans son
fils parce que ça nous manque lui qui
m'a appelé du nom mais merci j'ai vu en
fait j'ai pas besoin de vtt ce qui en
fait n'ont jamais de la vie en fait
c'est qu'on s'est rencontrés layan
ça moi pas
bon jeu non ouais on prend la photo et n
est pas trop oui c'est très bien photo
c'est mon patron et ses parts à des
ténors de parano parce que c'est un
petit caméo serrait la main ça vous
dérange qui combat la soirée vanity
quand même ça va je me disais mais
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on me le dise
moi je me suis dit pourquoi il le cache
pas dans son celi patrese peser pour
faire ça ce n'est pas possible
[Applaudissements]